أنا دكتور سانجاي جوبتا مضيف
بودكاست مطاردة الحياة في CNN
، فن المحادثة في
الواقع أصعب بكثير مما يدركه معظم الناس
على الرغم من أننا نفعل ذلك طوال حياتنا
جزءًا من المشكلة
، يفكر معظم الناس
فيما سيقولونه بدلاً من الاستماع
إلى ما يقوله الشخص الآخر في الواقع
لمجرد مقاومة هذا الدافع يمكن أن يؤدي إلى
محادثات أفضل وبالتالي
روابط أعمق شيء آخر
يطرح أسئلة على الأسئلة الكلاسيكية من ماذا
وأين ومتى وكيف يتم استخدامها
لسبب أسئلة مفتوحة
يعطيها  شخص آخر يتمتع بمزيد من الحرية في
سرد ​​قصته أيضًا ، ومن المهم جدًا ألا
تفترض أنك تعرف الإجابة ،
حاول أخيرًا أن تتعلم شيئًا ما يحول
هدفك من محاولة إقناع
شخص ما بشيء ما إلى رؤية ما
قد تتعلمه منهم ،
يقول المتحدث المحترف سيليست هيدلي إن هذه التقنية لديها
غيرت تمامًا قدرتها على التحدث إلى الأشخاص ،
يمكنك سماع المزيد حول كيفية تحسين
صحتك ومطاردة الحياة أينما
كنت  dcasts